[Musique]
logiquement le président de la
république à un ultimatum de 48 heures
pour désigner un nouveau premier
ministre
donc là le président de la république
s'il veut respecter la constitution il
est obligé de nommer un premier ministre
dans un délai de 48 heures après il y a
plusieurs scénarios le scénario le plus
constitutionnel le plus légal et
légitime c'est celui de la constitution
d'un nouveau gouvernement
la revendication de la rue libanaise
aujourd'hui c'est la formation d'un
gouvernement de technocrates pour une
sortie de la crise mais est ce que le
hezbollah et ça c'est l'écueil face à
cette revendication est ce que le
hezbollah acceptera-t-il cette défaite
est-ce qu'il va accepter vraiment de
laisser au peuple libanais le choix de
ses représentants
le choix de son gouvernement je pense
que pas et donc là on va dans on se
précipite vraiment dans un gouffre
d'incertitudes la guerre civile elle
s'est nourri des craintes identitaires
et des craintes entre les confessions
aujourd'hui ce scénario n'existe plus et
n'a plus aucune crédibilité aujourd'hui
le peuple libanais toute confession
confondue est unie sous une même
bannière qui est celle de l'unité
nationale de la démocratie
de l'éviction de tous les corrompus qui
sont au pouvoir aussi et de refus aussi
est également et surtout de du
terrorisme donc je pense que ceux qui
veulent déstabiliser le liban
aujourd'hui sont une minorité
on a quand même vu 35 à 40% du peuple
libanais tenir bon dans les rues pendant
13 jours et ça c'est énorme et c'est
presque un miracle